[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
parkland school shooting i just want you
know i'm really sorry
and i hope you give me
a chance
to try to help others it's your decision
to decide where i go and whether i live
or die we look ahead to next week's
sentencing trial plus the author behind
a bestseller and highly anticipated
movie is wanted for questioning in a
1995 murder case and the death of jalen
walker what autopsy results reveal about
his death we look at every single use of
force we look at the body cam footage
officers have to explain why they use
the force but first the accused buffalo
supermarket shooter is indicted on
dozens of federal charges long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian butler two months
after the deadly mass shooting at a
buffalo supermarket the accused shooter
is indicted by a federal grand jury back
in may 10 people were killed and three
others injured when the 19 year old
gunman opened fire in the days following
the shooting investigators revealed the
accused shooter was motivated by racism
writing a manifesto that supported white
supremacy
they say he specifically targeted black
people inside the store this week a
federal grand jury indicted the alleged
shooter on 27 counts including 14 hate
crimes charges and 13 firearms charges
a statement released by the department
of justice reads in part quote the
justice department fully recognizes the
threat that white supremacist violence
poses to the safety of american people
and american democracy we will continue
to be relentless in our efforts to
combat hate crimes if convicted the
accused shooter faces a lifetime prison
sentence or the death penalty right now
the attorney general has not yet decided
whether a death penalty sentence will be
pursued the suspect was also charged
with first-degree murder and entered a
not guilty plea just days after the
shooting spree on friday the tops
friendly supermarket the scene of the
shooting reopened for the first time
joining us today is federal clemency
expert and legal analyst tammy allison
and co-host terry austin tammy the
shooter was already indicted in state
court so what's the difference with
these charges
these charges these are federal hate
crime charges so these have a higher
penalty
with the fact that this individual chose
to perform this act of violence on the
perceived notion that these individuals
were
black so with federal hate crime charges
typically race their sexual orientation
religion so something about a protected
class of individuals is what the
motivation is behind the
defendant's uh crime so with the federal
hate crime charge in this situation we
know that that community was
predominantly african-american so at the
federal level he has been indicted
because of the fact that he chose this
uh community because they're
african-american and as we all know with
federal crimes he would go through a
federal
court in terms of
being prosecuted to eventually get a
conviction and sentencing at a federal
level absolutely now terry the death
penalty will be decided later but what
factors will go into deciding that and
what do you think the answer should or
even could be
well this is definitely a death penalty
eligible case 10 people were killed
three were injured it's a hate crime as
we've already discussed it's very
egregious but i think the prosecutors
and merrick garland himself they're
considering multiple issues they want to
look at the views of the victims
families and there's already been
meetings and they are saying that they
are in favor of capital punishment so
that's going to go into the
consideration but i think also civil
rights advocates those thoughts are
going to be into consideration also
there's a moratorium on the death
penalty but that doesn't mean the
prosecutors can't seek it they still can
yeah so at least for state charges
probably life in prison because it is
new york state but the feds can see the
death penalty will see what either
decide as they progress in this case
just ten days after the deadly buffalo
shooting a gunman opened fire at a robb
elementary school in uvalde texas
officials now say a police officer
previously scrutinized for checking his
cell phone was married to a teacher at
the school 19 students and two teachers
were killed when an 18-year-old gunman
opened fire at the elementary school 17
others were injured in the days
following the shooting first responders
faced backlash for a delayed response as
it took more than one hour to take down
the shooter officials face additional
criticism this week when surveillance
video from the school was released
showing an officer checking his cell
phone during the attack a texas state
representative now confirms the officer
was married to a teacher at the school
ava marella's she contacted her husband
from her classroom while she was on the
scene saying she was shot and dying the
officer tried to move forward but was
detained and his weapon was taken away
marella's died as a result of her
injuries
still ahead on law and crime daily the
author of a best-selling novel is wanted
from questioning in a murder overseas
but first autopsy results are released
in the death of jaylen walker how
officials say police officers involved
will be investigated
[Music]
welcome back autopsy results revealed
jalen walker
an unknown black man at the time was
shot 46 times by akron ohio police
officers on friday the medical examiner
released autopsy findings saying
walker's june 27 death was ruled a
homicide at the time officers pulled
walker over for a traffic violation body
camera footage shows a foot chase as
officers reported a weapon was
discharged out of walker's vehicle
according to a release from the akron
police department the officers believe
walker quote posed a deadly threat to
them after that they opened fire walker
was pronounced dead at the scene later
reports show there was a weapon in
walker's vehicle but it was not on him
when he was shot also he had no prior
criminal history on friday the medical
examiner noted walker was hit 46 times
across his entire body including his
face the medical examiner noted walker
had injuries to his heart and lungs and
died as a result of blood loss this week
the chief of the akron police department
addressed the uptick in officer-related
violence and the investigation process
for use of force
i'm not in any way shape or form
minimizing what happened here on june
27th at all that is just we're going to
look at what happened there bci is going
to do their criminal investigation we're
gonna do an internal investigation as
i've said since day one but overall when
you look at the number of complaints
that we've received in this city
uh for officers it's consistently since
2018 been around 50 51
with a low year in 2020 being 36.
again when you
lay that over 150 000 contacts i think
in one year was 181 000
that tells you something about this
police department and the officers that
are serving this community
but we will we look at every single use
of force we look at the body cam footage
officers have to explain why they use
the force and then decisions are made
whether or not the use of force was
within our policies or not if it was not
in in within our policies then the
disciplinary process will kick in
right now the officers involved in
walker's shooting are on paid
administrative leave as an investigation
into the police response continues
terry initial reports were that walker
was shot almost 60 times even we
reported that what does the autopsy
reveal about walker's injuries and why
we may be wrong or misguided
well there's a difference between the
preliminary findings they're just that
preliminary and the report that was
signed by the chief medical examiner
lisa kohler so we know that that is
going to be and is more detailed and
it's more thorough and they're looking
at each and every one of those wounds
and what dr kohler said was that there
were 41 entry wounds and five graze
wounds for a total of 46 and the
explanation between the initial
preliminary finding of 60 or more and
the 46 is that it is possible that some
of those entry wounds might have had
exit wounds as well and so they might
have been counted as additional but this
is the report and this is the one we
should go by at this point yeah
absolutely it makes sense now tammy a
homicide by loss of blood from dozens of
bullet wounds there's no surprise as to
the autopsy results but what does having
this information help in moving forward
with this investigation
i think having this information
is going to actually help the officers
the officers that you know shot him you
know it in this situation it does seem
reasonable to believe that they
thought that he was still armed there's
no way of knowing if in fact he did um
make some shots out of his car when he
was in the car if he still did not have
the firearm on him but i do think that
it's excessive the amount of shots that
the officers um
did on him that resulted in his death
it's extremely excessive there's no
reason why anyone needs to die by 40
plus bullets absolutely well we'll
continue to watch this case as
developments continue and make sure to
give you accurate information as it's
released in colorado the state rests its
case in the double homicide trial
against defendant kevin dean eastman a
man facing charges for the murders of
his ex-girlfriend and her new love
interest eastman is charged with two
counts of first-degree murder tampering
with a deceased human body and tampering
with physical evidence for allegedly
killing heather frank and local musician
stanley scott sessions on separate days
in february of 2020. frank and eastman
both had arrest warrants in connection
to sessions murder before frank's body
was found prosecutors say eastman slit
session's throat inside frank's
apartment and that eastman fatally shot
frank in the chest twice to silence the
only witness the session's killing they
say he then hit her body near burn pile
on the property of his new employer
investigators say eastman burned
session's body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body when he
was arrested at a nearby gas station on
thursday a dna analyst told
to the jury no blood was found on
several items of clothing except one
pair of pants
i examined this for the possible
presence of blood and blood was
indicated on the pants
i've circled the areas on the actual
pair of jeans when i visually examined
it i noticed a slight discoloration of a
tan color in a pattern
that i circled
because i noticed this discoloration
because it was not the normal red brown
like deep red brown of a heavy stain it
was a light stain
which could have been diluted by say
washing or some other method the dna
profile that was developed from the
cutting of the genes indicated a mixture
of two contributors this is very strong
support for the inclusion of mr sessions
on this pair of jeans mr bonnell
ms frank
and mr gallegos are excluded as
contributors to this profile
coming up on law and crime daily we had
to florida for the death penalty phase
of the parkland school shooter plus the
author of the best seller where the craw
dog sing may have a connection to an
unsolved murder why she's wanted for
questioning in zambia
[Music]
welcome back as where the crawdads sing
premieres in hollywood the author of the
book the movie is based on is one of her
questioning in connection to an african
murder author delia owens rose to fame
with the release of the 2018 bestseller
where the crawdads sing in the story the
protagonist stands trial for the murder
of her lover but in real life zambian
authorities want to speak to the book's
author about a 1995 murder she may have
witnessed at the same time owens and her
husband worked as wildlife convert
conservationist working to protect
elephants from poachers abc was on
location shooting a story about the
couple when gunshots rang out toward an
unidentified man when the story aired
the faces of the potential shooters were
blurred after that owens and her husband
left zambia and moved to idaho and later
divorced experts note there is no
statute of limitations on murder in
zambia
terry what does it mean to be wanted for
questioning are they suspects could they
get arrested can they even refuse to
show up
well you know getting questioned in
zambia is a little different from
getting questioned here here you can
question someone and try to figure out
what's going on and get information in
zambia a suspect has the right against
self-incrimination and as a matter of
fact the government has to produce
evidence against the person they can't
just have the person give them
information they have to have their own
independent investigation and
interestingly enough brian a confession
is only acceptable in zambia if in fact
it's voluntary so there's a lot of
differences in the processes over there
but i would suspect that if you're asked
to be questioned you will go in and
answer those questions absolutely now
tammy rappers like young thug and ghana
in atlanta are being prosecuted with
their musical lyrics with where the
crawdads sing having similarities to
this murder could a book be used in a
same or similar way
of course it probably should be let this
caucasian woman experience the same
things that these african-american men
are experiencing in atlanta use her
words in her book against her okay
question her question everything because
you know these are the things that uh
good books are made of you know so i do
believe that the words that she wrote in
the same way that the lyrics that these
individuals perform can and should be
used against her alright so no rap songs
or no books for me i don't want anyone
using my words against me in case
there's any future prosecution well also
in court overseas court resumes for
brittany griner as the wnba basketball
player is being detained in russia on
friday greiner's attorney brought
forward a letter from a united states
doctor urging the athlete to use medical
cannabis for pain treatment greiner has
been detained since february after she
was arrested at a russian airport when
less than a gram of cannabis oil was
discovered in her luggage while griner
pled guilty to the charges she denies
that she intentionally broke the law on
thursday the director of griner's
russian basketball league testified
saying she has played on the russian
team for seven years acting as a leader
and star player griner indicated she
plans to testify in the trial but says
she needs time to prepare a russian
judge previously ordered greiner remain
in the country until the trial has
concluded she could face 10 years behind
bars
when we come back attorneys are in the
final stretch ahead of the penalty phase
for the parkland school shooter still to
come hear who he argued should decide
whether he sent into life or death at
his coming trial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
jury is selected in the california case
that captured the nation 26 years ago as
reuben flores is stride for his
involvement in the disappearance and
murder of kristen smart rubin is charged
as an accessory to smart's 1996
disappearance while his son paul is
charged with her murder the two are
being tried at the same time but with
separate juries paul and kristen were
classmates at cal poly when she
disappeared more than two decades ago he
was allegedly the last person seen with
her as they returned to the dorms from
an off-campus party in may of 1996.
kristen's body has never been found but
she was declared legally dead in 2002.
it wasn't until april last year that
paul and his father were arrested in
connection to her disappearance opening
statements in both cases are scheduled
to begin on monday the trial is expected
to last through october
in florida attorneys are in their last
days of preparation for the penalty
phase of the parkland school shooter
it's been more than four years since the
then 19 year old opened fire on students
and staff at marjie stoneman douglas
high school 17 students and staff
members were killed while 17 others were
injured it took more than three months
to choose a jury a jury of seven men and
five women will ultimately decide
whether the parkland school shooter will
be sentenced to life in prison or to
death the 12-person panel and several
alternates will reportedly hear
testimony from a witness list of nearly
2 000 people in october of last year the
parkland school shooter pled guilty to
17 counts of murder and 17 more counts
of attempted murder which prompted his
case to head straight into the penalty
phase at that hearing he said he felt
the victims families should decide his
sentence
i'm trying my best to maintain my
composure and i just want to know i'm
really sorry
and i hope you give me
a chance
to try to help others if it's your
decision to decide where i go
whether i live or die i'm not sure if
you were talking to me or the victim's
families when you said you
but you do understand the state of the
law i went over that way yes i do and so
you know that it's neither me nor the
victims families that are going to be
in charge of imposing the death penalty
i think what mr um cruz was saying was
that ultimately in his heart he believes
it should be the victims families that
make the decision about life or death we
have however explained to mr cruz that
it will in fact be the jury that will
make that decision after the
presentation of evidence of aggravators
and mitigators in phase two
this i believe is just his personal
belief it is in conflict with the law
but he understands the law okay
opening statements are scheduled to
begin monday follow along for galvanic
gamble coverage on the law and crime
network
tammy we can probably guess what the
prosecution's opening will look like but
what could the opening uh be for the
defending the parkland school shooter
look like
you know i think the defense is probably
going to try to rely on his age
but i don't think that would be the
smartest strategy because the age of the
victims in this shooting
are around the same age as 10 or younger
and i just think that
a criminal defense attorney has you know
a duty to zealously advocate on behalf
of their client but i really just don't
see how anybody can jealously advocate
on behalf of this criminal that
conducted such a heinous crime it's
gross
well we'll see it when uh law and crime
covers the case but i agree with you
you're really plucking out of the air
for some kind of defense here terry what
do you think of the defendant's request
to have vic the victim's family decide
his fate rather than a jury
it's an odd request but in a sense it
makes sense because it's the victims who
were really impacted and arguably you
could say that they are the ones who
would benefit or be harmed depending on
what that sentence is but the judge made
it very clear that that's not the law in
the united states here a jury is going
to decide whether or not you get the
death penalty and it'll be based on
those victim impact statements and you
saw his attorney there explaining to him
that that's a different thing from how
you feel in your heart and how the law
is applied and the attorney tried to
make it clear to the judge that he
understood the difference between what's
in his heart and what the law is so
that's very important yeah something
that's necessary to go forward in the
case well tammy terry thank you very
much and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you